hey what's up guys my name is the Turner
and I just decided to do another blog I
mean last time did it blog was when I
ended up changing channels so it's been
like five months and from the primary
reason that I want to do a vlog what's
let you guys know what was happening
because I still get tweets ping like was
absolutely live in all that crap as well
as um I also wanted to touch a bit on
what I'm dare because I got a result in
so I'm mg I just I guess let you guys
know what I'm up to just because I can I
mean not that any of you care but why
not so um what about here is my studio
arts folio rights why do a subjective
school ball two yards so to follow your
best subject in which you basically need
to you know for this I guess unit of
work you know unit for the last unit
ever basically what you need to do is
create an artwork or two artworks
actually and you have to keep a folio of
your aesthetical decisions I guess so in
other words i'm doing video in specific
i'm doing visual effects so what i need
to do is essentially you know be like
okay i decided to collaborate this
because it you know a for example an
aircraft flying through a city it should
be like an action shot so in other words
i decided to put this vignette around
for that aesthetic or whatever and also
need to be like you know this jet has
you know global illumination and finally
gather enabled and Freddie Mac's for
these raisins you know aesthetically as
well as like actually I can just show
you guys um this is printouts
was huge well with the jets that down
give me a second unorganized cattle vlog
probably make like a vlogging channel
because our open half of you at least
won't want to see this I'll put it on
this channel I can make money off of gay
I don't I don't own any other cotton in
the trip journalist okay I can't buy car
this is particular wait hang on yup the
up there alright so basically for
example these are like you can't see
this but there's actually a jet there um
this one you might be able to see
slightly didn't simply deal no it's not
not that's fine um so in other words
this is like just with sky lighting and
this is with like a Sun light system
rendered in 3d studio max and then I you
know I sort of need to go through why I
added that in you know because it sort
of fits in the aesthetical style of mind
hidden purpose so in other words my
intended purpose of this artwork was to
create I guess fear and uncertainty in
the viewer and I've done that you know
by um basically making a lower a low
flying jet I'm just focus on this like a
lord flying jet essentially and it is
video as you can um as you can see so
the jet sort of flies through um through
the through the city and this is
melbourne city I took this footage about
early at the son of the year so if I
just get rid of Ju and I'm sort of see
the footage ah or you know against the
original footage without effects
so on yeah and I obviously need to show
you know from my potential directions
how I've basically have dominant so I
thought that's what I'm busy with right
now okay so like the second the second
largest vlog I guess was um a lot of
wanted to show you guys I guess a lot of
their results to sort of my reflection
on that roughly this is
all away
I probably have like one of those then
you look like maybe if you're walking
down the street would like a little holy
a whole thing work um sorry
so love them done I didn't do it to
about there I'm actually really happy
with the one but the way I did put
something over several folks so I hope
Otis is fine by the way might have to
pull spurn it but this is an iphone 4s
howzit at 1080p m which is actually like
really good as well you know the
megapixels economy it's thick burger
definitely this down so overall I came
208 which I thought was great I mean
it's my first have a lot of that I made
a game which much my vision had nothing
to do with them if they did like
apartments
but um audio I was actually really
surprised I mean it must just be my
musical talent or something yes a thing
is like right now if I say that I'm like
not talented people will be like year
did you actually really good and if I
say that yeah I am freaking amazing
people like I to that kind of sell off
himself so I guess I'm all right i'll
leave it at that but um I got number I
got 116 in audio which your music pretty
one which was surprised I'm sorry
someone decided call me juries that's
kind of a downside of shooting video on
your phone i guess but um ah very
surprising that i got on one of the
sixteenth an audio that's actually
pretty good like that's almost like the
top hundred out of 1400 six games
because i actually wrote the music for
those of you who were watching the live
stream or whatever all my on my Twitter
fed i actually wrote the music in a
total of seven minutes and the music
goes for seven minutes I literally got a
keyboard out and improvised the five
minutes for the main audio track and two
minutes for the menu track and and I
ended up going really well so I mean
thank you thanking everyone for the
support you gave me throughout this
light in there I'll probably be doing
the one in December I'm a some away
somewhere I'm not sure I would've
finished cool so maybe I'll maybe I will
be some way but um well I was running
outside anyway uh I guess I guess that's
pretty much all i wanted to say um I
mean that's what's happening in my
channel I'll be back no available like
15th November 15mm 16 I'll be back so I
wanna finish exams so on that's quick
update on my life and I'll see you guys
later bye